the documentary film the devil we know
is out on iTunes joining me to talk
about it is America's lawyer Mike
Papantonio who's featured in the film
for his work on the case against DuPont
and a toxic chemical called c8 which was
dumped into the Ohio River Valley you
can also find out more about the film at
the devil we know calm so perhaps since
we last spoke about this case a lot has
happened here and at this point there is
absolutely no doubt about what DuPont
knew and when they knew it I guess maybe
to start for people who don't know when
they hear Teflon they think we're
talking about the end product itself
those non-stick pans but we're actually
talking about a chemical that's used in
the production of Teflon so maybe we
start there and sort of how you became
aware of this and got involved well I
was hired by an attorney that had worked
on this case he was actually a corporate
defense attorney some pretty interesting
kind of combination but he was brought
in he had a family member that was
having serious serious physical problems
and he was actually and this was this is
15 years ago he was brought in to take a
look at it as he started looking at it
he found that people who are raising
cattle along the Ohio River or the
tributaries are along the Ohio River
that the cattle were dying of very
specific kinds of illnesses birth
defects all started looking exactly
alike the way that they would manifest
themselves the cancers that started
showing up in people all along the river
and so what he did is he asked me if I
would if I would try the case and so we
had we we had a couple of test cases
that we tried that we started off with
in Ohio in Columbus Ohio which is
typically how this is handled you'll
have in this case you had 3,000 people
that were affected you actually had
70,000 people that their water was
contaminated but 3,000 people actually
signed up and showed that they had very
specific kind of medical issues ranging
from gastro-intestinal to to cancer to
testicular cancer and liver cancer
kidney cancer
which were all consistent with the c8
exposure the their own documents du
Pont's own documents showed that they
knew as early as the 19th 1970s that
this this product had the ability cause
cancer and they dumped it in people's
drinking water all along the Ohio River
why do you think that this story which
when you consider the amount of people
that are in population areas that are
touched by the Ohio River I mean the
number of people affected by this is
staggering if you include all of the
ways people are affected by this why
don't you think the story got the
attention that for example the Flint
water crisis did when we compared you
know strictly speaking a lot of people
were affected by this runoff well the
media didn't have they didn't have to
worry about advertisers with the Flint
story there were no there were no
corporations that you could point your
finger - there are only politicians that
the media could go after here the story
was in front of the media the national
media for about 30 years
and they chose to do nothing because
DuPont was such a huge advertiser for
them I mean they were massive advertiser
for the media so the trade-off was we
won't talk about this you keep spending
two million dollars a year with us on
this ad campaign and we'll let things go
that's exactly what the media did the
meet the media was owned and operated by
DuPont for three decades and so that's
why this story did not really surface
until actually we went to trial and the
jury came back four times and hammered
DuPont four times and not only not only
said that you did wrong but they
punished them for the conduct was so
callous it was such ugly conduct and so
then all of a sudden the media had to
actually be journalists rather than
advertising agents for DuPont and so
that that's when the story actually
started surfacing story's been out there
a long time people were drinking this
water people in most cities around the
country have it in their drinking water
it's so you know there's this is this
film shows the film is I got to tell you
I've been involved in several
documentaries David the filmmakers in
this first of all are huge award
winning filmmakers but they did so well
at the Sundance Film Festival that the
folks at Sundance determined that there
were three films that they needed to
that they needed to help get the word
out on those three films this was one of
them because of the social and cultural
ramifications the health ramifications
of this of this catastrophe that was
caused by 3m and DuPont primarily yeah I
mean the film is great not only in terms
of how its produced and it shows both
the kind of personal impact on the
victims it shows the legal process that
was going on and and and and shows how
those two things relate but it's also so
important in my mind because what you
just described about corporate media's
reluctance to cover the story we have a
justice system that as you know because
of the space you work in it
overwhelmingly focuses on street crime
and not nearly enough on corporate crime
and also white-collar crime corporate
media mirrors that corporate media also
focusing on the salacious and sort of
neat and compact street crime stories
versus these corporate malfeasance
stories so you it's not from the
documentaries and independent media I
don't know how we would even learn about
these things you wouldn't no no you
would not have that's the interesting
thing about it here's something that is
so ubiquitous it's it's just out there
and so such a broad expanses this film
talks about they're even finding it in
polar bears in the Arctic so that shows
you that it's virtually in everybody's
blood at this point God didn't put it
there
DuPont or 3m put it there and now so
what what the industry did and the film
is very good on showing how the industry
captured the EPA and they not only
captured media they captured the EPA and
they they actually were hiring people
out of the EPA they would go to them and
say Joe we know you're doing this study
but by the way how would you like to
come to work for us for three hundred
thousand dollars a year you know you're
making a hundred now what do you think
and so all of a sudden this revolving
door started with the EPA with the DEP
the Department of Environmental
Protection all up and down
the Ohio River Valley but you mentioned
the DOJ this is a really ugly part of it
the both the Eric Holder administration
had all of this information every bit of
it
they had possession of it they had
reviewed it they chose not to prosecute
even though any I you know I've been a
prosecutor and I can tell you they had
so much material that it was virtually
impossible for them not to get a
conviction of several of the people that
were involved in this but they chose not
to because as you point out these people
they look different they're dressed up
in suits you know they have MBAs they're
not they don't look like the kid on the
street corner in a hoodie that goes to
prison for life if he's caught three
times selling drugs these people were
not even investigated by Eric Holder or
by ask Kraft I could go right down the
you know right down the path well I want
to talk about immigrants it made no
there was no difference between the way
the Democrats handled it in the way the
Republicans handled it it was all about
DuPont handing out big amounts of money
to all of these politicians yeah when we
would talk to you including about this
case and others you during the Obama era
you were very hard on the Obama EPA and
on the Obama Justice Department and and
correctly so what's going on with the
current EPA in the Justice Department oh
it's worse I mean you know we well I say
it's worse I don't know that you could
have gotten that the last EPA was
basically dysfunctional you know granted
the people that they had appointed
didn't look as bad but they were they
were corporatist
now we now we have for example the the
head of the the chief litigator for BP
with this new EPA chief litigator for pp
is in charge of the Department of
Justice the environmental prosecution
for environmental cases in the country
he's the guy in charge of that he was
just appointed by Trump approved by both
Democrats and Republicans the guy's a
thug I mean I as you know we handled the
BP case we handle them all along because
he's an absolute thug and so but now
he's in charge of the EPA so so yeah the
he made the news we heard about him but
to tell it to tell you there was any
real big difference in the appointments
of Obama it would be very it's a tough
stretch really to say yeah they sounded
better on paper but when it came to
really enforcement they were really
nothing but Wall Street corporatists
they were Democrats yeah this guy's
Republican yeah but he's a corporatist
he's a corporatist environmental agency
leader right so there's no difference we
want to thank god this is this is
different this film is really good at
talking about these issues we're talking
about right now
I mean these people did a wonderful job
on this film yeah there's a scene in the
film actually and this is what I wanted
to talk to you about next which which
sort of puts out there the idea that if
an individual were to show up at a river
or you know at a downtown somewhere
where people are hanging out and start
sprinkling arsenic around that would be
a crowd like they would get arrested for
that that would be a very specific crime
but that they'd go defensively what
corporations and in this case what was
happening with c8 is this bigger than a
Justice Department like is this more
about the protection that corporate
entities provide that lead to basically
fines being paid and no real people
going to prison well there's a you know
there is within the area of the law
there's this really he's kind of a nut I
mean he really is a nut his name is
Posner he's a federal judge up in the
Chicago area and he he is he is
engineered and pioneered the way that we
ought to review cases and he came up
with the economics of law yeah a
corporation may do something completely
deplorable they might kill people they
might poison people and give him cancer
but this idiot I've very easily call him
an idiot he is he's an egghead an idiot
named Posner he's a federal appellate
court up around Chicago he he said well
yeah we're going to kill people but
have to look at the economics of killing
those people do people are people
employed at that corporation so it may
be it's okay to kill people it may be
that there's the economy projected
because of that conduct well maybe it's
okay to kill people that's the new norm
within the federal judiciary and
certainly is the new norm within the
Department of Justice I just can't tell
you how bad I I just almost can't put
words to how bad Eric Holder was and we
thought he was a hero didn't we oh he's
he's he's it appointed by Obama he must
certainly gotta look out for consumers
where he didn't he did not he is we see
the same thing with opioids I'm seeing
exactly the same Eric Holder footprints
on the opioid litigation as I saw in
this litigation with DuPont so go figure
you know that's just the reality you
know there it's tribal politics is the
only reason we say that we're going to
preserve him as a hero he's not a hero
last thing I want to talk about when we
last spoke about this there were sort of
two I believe major plaintiffs at the
time and there have since been some
verdicts what's the sort of totality of
the cases and verdict so far on c8 well
I mean the verdicts have range anywhere
from two million to eight million
dollars I mean if they had had DuPont
not come out with a first phase of
settlement we would have continued being
in trial now the way the settlement is
built there for next five years people
come forward coming forward with these
injuries have the right to to either try
them or settle their cases so it was
built with that in mind because there's
some latency to this you know you don't
you're not exposed to see a day one and
have cancer day two so there's some
latency involved and and that's that's
why these people still have the right to
come forward you can find out more about
the film the devil we know at the devil
we know dot-com it's also available on
iTunes and it features attorney Mike
Papantonio who's been talking to us
about the case
thanks as always for talking to us thank
you David